you never know where the bad is gonna
come from you're about to become the
queen of auradon mal you and Ben are
going to make the world a better place
and one day your daughter is going to
attend Arden prep alongside Evie Audrey
uma and Jane's kids and you never know
where the heroes are gonna come from
either we really wish we could see what
the next generation of descendants is
going to look like so we got a little
creative if you know what they say the
poison apple doesn't fall far from the
tree we're still waiting for descendants
4 to get the green light so in the
meantime we thought it'd be fun to
theorize on possible spin-offs keep
watching to find out what the future
generation of descendants are going to
act like and look like you won't believe
who mouths daughter is going to be best
friends with Loomis daughter bloom and
her mother Ursula weren't really close
but that's not going to be the case for
uma and her future daughter
if the descendants naming trend
continues we think umas daughter's name
would be Ursa just like her mother
Ursa would have strong leadership skills
she would be a great public speaker and
friend she'd be able to sail a boat's
from a very young age and by the time
she was a teenager
Ursula would have her own ship and crew
Ursula would be one of the best pirates
our don has ever seen and that's because
she was raised by not one but two
pirates if you haven't guessed it yet
hairy hook would be IRS's dad that means
that her full name would be Ursa hook
the famous granddaughter of the baddie
Captain Hook Ursa wouldn't carry around
a fake hook like her dad but she'd
probably wear a silver necklace with a
hook pendant Ursa would have a great
personality she would be feisty and
confident like her mom's yes sarcastic
and witty like her dad she would easily
be one of the most popular girls at
auradon prep but she would never use her
popularity to bully others at first
glance you could never tell that hairy
hook was IRS's father and that's because
she would look exactly like her mom
Ursa would have long curly brown hair
with aqua tips she'd have the same skin
tone as her mom and big brown eyes too
she would make her mom proud by sporting
the color aqua but pay homage to her dad
by always wearing a black leather jacket
Ursa would be one of the most powerful
vks in auradon she would inherit all of
her mom's powers Puma would eventually
give Ursa her seashell necklace and uma
and Ursa would turn into Cecilia's and
go for long swims under the sea despite
being raised by two vks Ursa would never
refer to herself as the bad guy but
that's not to say that she hasn't spar
taking in some mischievous behavior Ursa
would be best friends with Gil's
daughter who would also be a pirate what
do you think of the name Ursa tell us
what you'd name umas daughter in the
comments
Carlos's daughter villains don't make
the best parents but they make fantastic
grandparents Carlos his mom karela de
Ville wasn't exactly nice to him when he
was growing up but she made up for that
by being a fantastic grandmother to Ala
de Vil we think Ella would be a great
name for Carlos and Janes daughter after
all it pays homage to both Cruella and
Cinderella
and since Jane's mom the fairy godmother
was first introduced in the Disney movie
Cinderella it just makes sense if the
shoe fits right L avoid be the sweetest
girl in auradon she would learn the
meaning of true friendship from her dad
and she would be a total animal lover -
dude the dog would eventually have
puppies and Ella would keep the runt of
the litter and name her dudette just
like Jane Ella would be super organized
she'd planned the school dances and
she'd be coins the Arden party planner
Ella would be incredibly intelligent
she'd be her graduating classes
valedictorian and she'd become a total
tech whiz thanks to her dad
Ella would take from Jane's side of the
family boyfriend and girlfriend we can
hold hands instead of slugging Giraud
she'd have the same long brown hair and
bright blue eyes as her mom but she
wouldn't dress like her mom in the
slightest Ella would look like a total
--vk in her black white and red leather
outfits specifically designed by her
aunt Evie
unlike Jane Ella would be raised around
magic her fairy godmother would teach
her everything she knows and she'd even
be allowed to
her wand despite looking like a total
villain ella would be super sweet and
caring she would never practice black
magic and would defend our Adan in the
blink of an eye
she'd be just as brave and honest as her
parents alla with love school and one
day dream of becoming the headmistress
of our Dunn prep Carlos and Jane's girl
would be best friends with Jays daughter
they would go on wild adventures
together and literally be inseparable
what do you guys think of the name Ella
tell us what you would name Carlos's
daughter in the comments below
V's daughter Evie's mom the Evil Queen
raised her to believe that status beauty
and wealth were the three most important
things a girl could have you just find
yourself a prince with a big castle and
the mother-in-law way it didn't take
long for Evie to find out that that was
all a lie
which is why that's the last thing she
would ever teach her daughter his
perfect descendants fashion Evie would
name her daughter Eve and she'd grow up
to be a mixture of both Evie and Doug II
would have the perfect combination of
beauty and brains she would be one of
the most brilliant students at our Adhan
Pratt and would constantly compete with
Ella to have the highest grades but on
top of being a total whiz Eve would also
share her mother's love for fashion Evie
would inspire her to start a clothing
line at 13 years old of which she would
name Eve's Apple and Eve would make
suits and gowns for the students at ours
on prep on top of being a business savvy
go-getter Eve would also have a nerdy
side her dad is Doug after all which is
why she'd love music as much as she
loves fashion Eve would be a proud
member of the Arden preps marching band
and would play the trumpet just like her
dad
despite being a sweet and soft-spoken
person he would never be a pushover
anyone who tried to make fun of her for
being in the marching band would live to
regret it
Eve would be somewhat of a klutz except
for when she's walking down the runway
evil Queens Eve will have the same dark
blue hair color as her mom she'll be one
of the prettiest girls in school and
she'll never go anywhere without her
tiara she'll have her mother's brown
eyes but her dad's poor eyesight's but
she'll opt for contacts instead of
glasses Eve will be one of the good guys
and her grandmother the Evil Queen will
teach her how to use spells but she'll
make sure to filter out the bad ones II
we'll be best friends with diseased
otter Izzy who will be an aspiring
photographer they'll spend their days
taking photoshoots and creating new
outfits tell us what you think of the
name Eve in the comments Audrey's
daughter Audrey may have been raised by
Princess Aurora and Prince Philip but
she turned out to be a total villain and
Audrey's daughter will have a mean
streak in her too
she'll be the baddest girl in Arden prep
but every now and then she'll show her
true colors despite coming off as a mean
girl Audrey's daughter will be one of
the best friends a person could ever
hope for Audrey would continue the
descendants naming trends by naming her
daughter Aubrey Aubrey would mimic her
mom's personality and make her proud but
when no one's watching she would let her
guard down and be kind to those closest
to her but unlike her mom Aubrey
wouldn't throw her princess status in
everyone's face wearing dresses and
going to balls just wouldn't be her
thing Aubrey would rather wear
comfortable clothes that she convincin
Aubrey would value power and be super
competitive she would be the best fencer
in auradon and pirates would constantly
try to recruit her Audrey would be the
daughter of Chad and would have
Cinderella as a grandmother but I'm like
Chad Aubrey wouldn't be scared of
anything she'd constantly be looking for
the next adventure and Audrey would
often scold her daughter for not being
ladylike but that wouldn't face her one
bit partner-in-crime
Thank You Aubrey would look more like
Chad than she would Audrey she would
have a pale complexion a light dusting
of freckles and big blue eyes she would
keep her hair shorts making it easier to
fight the one trait that would tie
Audrey and Audrey together would be
Opry's vibrant pink hair Audrey and her
daughter was violet but in the end
Audrey would be super proud of her for
being her own person Audrey wouldn't
have any magical powers of her own but
what she lack in powers she'd make up
for in skills just like her parents
Aubrey is a master manipulator she
always gets what she wants but that
doesn't mean that she doesn't work hard
to get it
Audrey wouldn't have a lot of friends
due to her pushing people away but one
person would see through her mean girl
act and quickly become best friends with
her
mouths daughter Mouse spent most of her
life trying to follow in her mom's
footsteps
that is until she realized that she
wanted to be her own person Mao's
daughter is going to struggle with the
same exact thing we think mouths
daughter would be named Mallory but let
us know if you prefer another name in
the comments being the daughter of the
queen and king of auradon is no small
feat and Mallory will have some big
shoes to fill from a very young age
despite wanting to make her mom and dad
proud Mallory will dream of going on
adventures and will dislike the idea of
one day becoming Queen
despite her reluctance to wear the crown
Mallory will have excellent leadership
and decision-making skills to have a
solution to every problem and to be one
of the bravest people in auradon but
when it comes to school Mallory won't be
too invested she'll be naturally street
smart and see mathematics as her own
sworn enemy when need be Mallory will be
diplomatic like her father King Ben but
she'd much rather be on the front lines
instead of cooped up in an office
Mallory will appear super close to her
grandfather Hades and he'll teach her
how to bring her powers to the next
level just like Mao Mallory will have
the ability to transform into a dragon
she'll be able to cast spells brew
potions and hold her own in a sword
fight Mallory will be a carbon copy of
mal but then won't mind one bit she'll
have bright green eyes dark purple hair
and the same complexion as her mom
everyone will recognize the princess of
auradon in a heartbeat so she'll often
use charms to conceal her appearance
believe it or not but Mallory will be
best friends with Aubry they'll bond
over their parents expectations of them
and become besties despite their family
history and that's a wrap before you go
tell us who your favorite descendants
couple is and be sure to give their
future kid name thanks for watching and
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up subscribe to the things for
more fun content we'll catch you next
time